a man in the west valley lucky to be
alive after police say his neighbor shot
him in the head it all happened a few
weeks ago at an apartment complex near
durango and sahara now austin culp is
sharing his story to try and help others
stay safe sasha loftus joins us with
this story you'll only see on eight
denise the man i spoke with tonight says
he's so grateful to be alive but this
entire situation has been really tough
he'd had trouble with his neighbor
before but didn't ever think things
would get violent like this
austin kulp is still recovering weeks
after he was shot in the head they said
there's still some bird shot and
concrete in my head it all happened
right outside his front door when he
says his neighbor who police have
identified as 49-year-old tyrone blanks
approached him with an ar-15 style
weapon turned around and went up the
stairs and then he shot the bullet
grazed his skull and left a hole in this
wall
blanks was later arrested after an
hours-long standoff with police i looked
down at my phone and all i see is that
my brother was shot in the back of the
head jordan milhoff austin's sister and
roommate says she was shocked when she
heard the news
they'd had run-ins with blanks before
but say they never expected things to
escalate this far even if it's not a big
deal it can turn into something like
this now as they try to get back on
their feet austin and jordan are forced
to face a mountain of medical bills and
say they're now being evicted from their
apartment it's hard i don't even have
insurance the situation that's
incredibly difficult to say the least
but no matter what austin says he's just
grateful to still be here thank god i'm
alive
now an arrest report shows blanks had a
prior felony conviction in new york he
now faces multiple charges including
attempted murder and possession of a gun
by a prohibited person if you'd like to
help austin and his sister we have a
link to their gofundme on our website